but why but why would you pay why would
you plan for failure if you want a
successful relationship it's not
planning for failure it is planning for
failure because sweetheart you are
literally saying that I would like a
second house in case goes solid in
case I have an argument something I
sleep on the couch I go tomorrow why
don't you just work on not being
argumentative
um because it's just inevitable if
you're married to somebody if you're
married to someone you're gonna leave
with them for the rest of your life
you're all definitely going to disagree
on something that's something we should
agree on yes you can't say it's not
going to happen you're gonna agree I
agree with you on that you are correct
you are correct but you don't need a
separate house to run away to why don't
you just go for a walk in the park all
right my walk to my house isn't it